"Criminal Minds" was one of the most successful
shows on television during its 15 seasons
on the air.
The crime drama produced an astounding 324
episodes in that period of time, which is
a huge accomplishment for any series.
For a while there, it even seemed like the
saga had finally closed the book, but fans
of the CBS ratings smasher can rest assured
knowing that a highly anticipated revival
will be available to stream on Paramount+
in the near future.
That means the Behavioral Analysis Unit still
has yet more cases to crack in the future,
and it also means fans will get to spend more
time with all the show's characters, whether
they love them or loathe them.
While the show's compelling murder mysteries
are a big part of the appeal, it was always
the characters themselves, and their relationships
with one another, that gave "Criminal Minds"
its heart, keeping viewers coming back, season
after season.
Some of the protagonists are beloved fan favorites
whose company will never get old.
Others, meanwhile, have made an impact for
the wrong reasons — even those played by
famous actors.
Some of these well-regarded actors may have
some great credits to their name, but fans
of "Criminal Minds" can be pretty particular.
Looking back, it appears that there was one
specific character who really angered the
fans, to the point where they even petitioned
to have the character written off the series.
"Criminal Minds" was known for featuring the
occasional big name stars throughout the years,
most of whom have been well-received by the
show's die-hard audience.
That said, Jennifer Love Hewitt rubbed some
fans the wrong way, despite joining "Criminal
Minds" on the back of successful programs
like "The Ghost Whisperer" and movies such
as "I Know What You Did Last Summer."
Hewitt's character, Kate Callahan, first appeared
in the Season 10 premiere episode.
Presented as a stable, motherly figure with
a happy home life, albeit with a tragic past
— namely, a sister and brother-in-law who
were killed in the Pentagon attack on 9/11
— she is also given relatable traits such
as an affinity for cute animal photos and
a love of karaoke.
"Karaoke at the Benjamin."
"Excuse me?"
"You were singing karaoke at the Benjamin
the night it closed."
Considering that Hewitt herself is a popular
actress who often earns fan adoration in her
other work, the producers probably thought
that her character Kate was going to be an
instant hit with viewers.
It didn't go that way — but to be fair,
the odds were firmly stacked against her success
from the get-go.
When the actress joined the series, she had
to fill the void left behind by Jeanne Tripplehorn,
who had played Alex Blake.
Critics of the newcomer believed that developing
a new character distracted from the more important
elements of the series.
Now, Kate's warmth and familial ties certainly
earned her some die-hard fans.
However, those who didn't agree with her inclusion
went to some drastic measures to try to have
her removed.
The dissatisfaction with Jennifer Love Hewitt's
character, believe it or not, even caused
one fan to launch a Change.org petition — titled,
rather straightforwardly, "Write Jennifer
Love Hewitt's character off Criminal Minds"
— claiming that she took away screen time
and distracted from the other agents and cases
in the BAU.
Others explained that they just didn't like
the character and found Hewitt's performance
and the writing for her character to be hokey.
For what it's worth, that particular petition
only acquired 42 signatures, but it highlighted
some of the issues some viewers had with the
new cast member.
"There are dozens of us…
Dozens!"
In the end, Hewitt did depart from the popular
series ... but not for the reasons one might
expect, and not because of the petition.
Hewitt did eventually give her critics their
wish, leaving "Criminal Minds" at the end
of the season in 2015.
But it wasn't because of any fan gripes -- instead,
it was because she became pregnant with her
second child, and the due date — and her
desire to fully invest her time in the new
arrival — conflicted with the time period
in which the show's eleventh season was set
to start shooting.
Speaking to Entertainment Weekly, Criminal
Minds' showrunner Erica Messer explained,
"Jennifer wanted to be able to give this second
baby everything she gave her first, and that's
taking time off to be a full-time mom [...] We
wrote to that, and that's how season 10 ends."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.